PROFESSOR: OK, this is where
we were teaching the class.
This is the new ESG kitchen.
But we don't use it
only for this class.
It's a community kitchen.
So all the students in
the community can use it.
And on Friday, we have
a community lunch.
So one or two students
or staff members
cook for everybody else,
and this is where we usually
eat all together.
But for the "Speak Italian
With Your Mouth Full" seminar,
we were using this
board whenever
we needed to discuss some
grammar, some vocabulary.
Right now there is
some physics problem.
That's good, because
they're my students.
So I know that they have
solved the problem set.
And I also had a portable
whiteboard in case
we needed to visualize
some of the grammar,
for example, while
we were cooking.
So this is the common lounge.
Well, right now there is nobody
around, because it's a holiday.
But usually there are
students at every time
of the day or night.
It's open 24/7.
And the students come here
to work on problem sets
together, or just
sometimes socialize.
We have a piano.
We might have somebody play
the piano while the others are
solving problems at the board.
And then we have our classrooms
on both sides of the hallway.
I can show you.
Yeah, so this is a classroom
where I usually teach physics.
And as you can see,
it's pretty small.
We have about 10, 12 seats.
It's very different
from the classrooms
in the regular
curriculum where you
might take physics but with
another few hundred students.
Here everybody knows
each other by name,
so they can really
work together.
And, well, I use the board,
so part of my classes
are still lecture style.
But then we work
in groups, as you
can see from the
structure of the table.
We have chairs all around.
So apart from the main board, I
also use portable whiteboards.
And the idea is that
during the class,
we can split and solve problems
in groups of two or three
people, which makes it
much more interactive.